all can find our own truth as long as we
put ourselves an environment where we
don't tolerate anything less than them I
used to be the smart I made sure how the
smartest guy in the room yeah now if I'm
the smartest guy in the room I'm in the
wrong you're in the wrong room
[Music]
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up belief nation it's Evan I am sick but
I still believe in you and this channel
is still designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
cup of tea and sip on today's message
give energy over to you tony robbins
also if you want to know what tony
robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help build
your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below the fact that human beings our
strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions so if
you want to change your life my friends
you've got to change your physiology and
you got to change your focus
[Music]
everything in my world is based on
coming up with the outcome that will
serve and then going at it but most the
time your approach going at it doesn't
work no one else knows that but you know
you can see it doesn't work so it's
constantly changing your approach until
you can get where you want to go and I
enter an audience and I'm gonna give a
talk of any sort I do a huge amount of
homework in advance I prepare I see is
there but then when I stand up here I
wouldn't be sitting like this I'm
scanning constantly who I'm looking for
the people think it's bull I'm gonna
have the people who got dragged there
I'm not looking for the people clapping
for me you know that those people will
always be there and there's some people
clap even if you're terrible so you
don't want to other people's view make
you feel good I'm looking for who isn't
there so that I can reach them so I can
show them that there's something real
here because you know most people don't
know who I am they'd see you know ten
thousand people jumping in a stadium and
I got it's just a big motivational pump
up I've never been a motivator it's
never opened up when I've been about I
think motivation is useful is like a
warm bath you should probably take a
bath or a shower every day but you need
more than that you need strategy and I
but what I really believe is energy most
of us grew up and right now most of you
are learning and the traditional style
you did leave when you're in school you
were trained to go to your seat and be
silent and be polite and nice but the
world we live in today isn't like that
the world today if somebody sits down
and waits for someone to tell them what
to do they're in trouble so my approach
is constantly stimulating and seeing
what's real getting people to be raw and
getting to truth you know those corny as
it is the truth sets us free and we all
can find our own truth as long as we put
ourselves an environment where we don't
tolerate anything less than that now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question the day I want to
know what is it that gives you energy
for me it's actually making these videos
even though I'm sick yeah I actually
have more energy than I did before so
thank you guys for that but I want to
hear your answer leave it down in the
comments below
think and say and do certain things and
believe certain things but if you carry
an energy that's different it doesn't
matter what you're trying to manifest
and let me give you an example there's a
lot of people that date the same person
again and again and again or they have
the same business problem again and
again again yeah the same obstacles yeah
no matter what they do you seemed it
what why why is this always happening
yes it's because you carry an energy I
drink what I analyzed and you know I
went to India and kind of learned this
stuff about myself is number one my
siblings were all hyper intelligent
students they all went to the Ivy
League's so I kind of chip on my
shoulder that I didn't go to Harvard
Penn or Columbia okay my siblings were
much more academic so I had that going
then when I was little as hyper and they
were good students my grandma who my mom
was a teacher would take us after school
was this wise old kind of Yoda type of
character yeah and she would always say
to me I go grandma I'm bored right boy I
don't want to study yes he goes only
stupid people get bored smart people
think things to do
well this changed my cellular memory
that's right neural pathways and in
demised code yes DNA so my energy
shifted what did that mean though that
means I projected my insecurities about
being stupid yes maybe an ego-driven guy
yes who then surrounded himself with the
wrong people yeah I used to be the smart
I made sure how the smartest guy in the
room yeah now if I'm the smartest guy in
the room I'm in the wrong you're in the
wrong room
start checking in with your thoughts and
how you're feeling each day so outside
about gratitude practice which I'm going
to kind of talk about as well this is
probably the number one fastest way that
you can start changing your life and I'm
going to tell you about the ripple
effect that happens so it's checking in
to see where you're at what emotion are
you feeling in that moment so if you
wake up in the morning and you're
anything like me I don't necessarily
wake up in the best Boone at all so I
really need to start figuring out how to
up level my feelings right because our
feelings are the best indicators of what
we're attracting what we're going to
attract that day how we're gonna feel
maybe what's going to come into our life
who we're going to end up talking to
because truly truly I know that we are
all
on a we're all vibrating at a different
frequency so if you are a really
positive excited happy person who knows
that great things are gonna come your
way or who's always thinking positive
you're gonna attract that same type of
person and I can see this through my
life as I've really started to uplevel
my life and my thoughts in my business
the people that are being drawn to me so
you really do it really is like attracts
like so what we want to do is we want to
get you into that mode right those
people that you're like wow they can
just walk into a room and you just feel
their energy they're just vibrating so
high or maybe they're just always so
happy or they always you you just want
to be around them because you want a
piece of what they have so how do we get
there how do we become one of those
people when you wake up in the morning
maybe if you are at a low point or
you're thinking about all the things
that you have to do that day what is a
thought or what is something that you
can do to get yourself to the next best
reachable thought so I don't want you to
think that you have to go from zero to a
hundred in that split-second it's
basically going from zero to five to ten
to twenty to fifty and working your way
up so it's one thought at a time so
maybe you wake up and you just say three
things that you're grateful for every
single morning you let yourself really
experience being grateful for it really
think about why you're grateful and then
what you're gonna do is as as you mosey
down the stairs to get your cup of
coffee you say three more things you're
grateful for or I'm so grateful that I
have a job today because of what it
allows me to do and you really start
letting that sink in and you think of
something that maybe you're excited
about something that you could create
something that you love about yourself
it's this constant up leveling of your
thoughts so it's guiding your thoughts
right so instead of just being mindless
which what happens we're we're imperfect
human beings right so when we're
mindless and when we don't guide our
thoughts they're gonna go to chaos
they're gonna go to craziness they're
gonna go to overwhelm because life is
crazy and we're constantly getting
sidetracked we're constantly getting
distracted it's literally people's
full-time job on TV on Instagram on
whatever we're doing to distract us
right they want us to be their consumer
they want us to be completely distracted
they want us to go to this fast-food
place do this thing do that thing so we
need to bring it back to a mindful place
so really that's what we're doing when
we up level those thoughts is how do you
bring it back from crazy town so bring
it on back and then guide it to that
next best thought right because the next
best thought is gonna attract another
good thought attract another good
thought and it attract another good
thought if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon if you want more Tony Robbins
check out the eight hour video we did on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I'm very excited about the session
because one of the biggest challenges
for people's everybody wants a better
quality of life
everybody wants life to be greater